I mentioned earlier about Jeremy
Clarkson who I'd listen I get on phone
with glass and now but just to remind
viewers he did punch me in the head and
I got a sky which comes up when I have a
tan like I do now from his right fist so
it's not like we've been the easiest to
bed there we are easiest of bed fellows
over the years I've literally born the
scars of Clarkson so I'm not going to be
his greatest cheerleader in a moment of
Misfortune all I would say is this is
that he could not have issued a more
sincere apology than he did today and as
I've always suspected about the work
Brigade the moment you do that they
don't accept it and by the way Harry's
the king of the wokies they just Chuck
it straight back in your face
and I I mean Tessa we didn't discuss
this but here's my problem with it if it
can't he apologize enough I mean is
there no apology oh it's acceptable if
you're not rummage around in the small
print it's because the grand Tours
apparently been pulled by Amazon Prime
that apology
I'd rather wait why do you think
Clarkson apologize why dip you down in
your typical do you think he should be
canceled for everything
to be honest I think we've had quite a
lot of clocks in over the years and time
to bring on a fresh lot yeah I would
have you think he should be canceled for
that reason canceled he's still platform
I think maybe if the Amazon Prime think
it's time for them to shuffle off then
perhaps
I haven't confirmed that I mean he won't
answer the question do you think he
should well that's a good question I
think there should be a punishment for
that level of virtual I would like to
see and don't shoot me I would like to
see some modification to the to the to
include misogyny in those haters
we're talking on a daily term
institutional I agree
so what about all the hideously
misogynistic things that Harry says in
his book oh not back to that not back to
the prep school teacher whom he made
last yeah when he was 11 years old
you've got to let me finish I'm talking
about the matron that he called ugly and
greasy and didn't make the boys horny
I'm talking about the newspaper
executive who is absolutely viciously
misogynist about I'm talking about
Camilla who he calls a dangerous villain
blah blah blah blah blah blah the book
is laced with misogyny so I agreement
you shouldn't be taken more seriously
what about he starts with himself
first of all would you have preferred
that he pretended he was a saint at prep
school and never did that it wasn't my
question
my question was very simple why should
he be allowed to be a misogynist but
anyone who dares to be a misogynist
about his wife he wants to get cancer I
just don't think you can compare the
idea of someone of course you can't
being said liked on a cellular level
greater down the street naked of course
having Humanity we're describing a
tabloid actually something what he said
about a female leader was actually
pretty well
actually it was misogynist sexist and
revolting yeah uh but anyway let's move
on I want to talk to Stephen Bates
former guy Guardian World correspondent
age Stephen I didn't even know the
guardian had a royal correspondence so
that was a bit of a shock to me so
congratulations on on that uh on that
title uh but thank you for joining me
look I wanted to get you on because I
expect you to launch a spirited full
frontal defense of tabloid newspaper but
I do think you've raised very
interesting points in your column about
all this which is that Harry's real
point of visceral hatred is that the
British tabloids in particular were
directly to blame for Princess Diana his
mother's death and you wrote it a column
really saying that isn't born by facts
no that's right I mean I watched the ITV
interview uh the other Sunday like
millions of other people did and uh as
you see we had this riff about
um the tabloids uh and the paparazzi
causing his mother's death that wasn't
actually uh what I discovered and found
I was the Guardians man in Brussels at
the time and I was sent down first thing
that morning to help the coverage of
course and I got on into a cab at the
guard you know to go to the guardian
office and the cabbie this is five or
six hours after the accident said that
driver must have been mad to drive into
that tunnel at that speed he said
there's a very bad camber and there's a
Twist in the tunnel and anyone who
drives in at that sort of speed you have
to stick to 30 kilometers an hour he
said yeah anyone who went in at the sort
of speed that car was being driven at uh
must have been mad and we now know after
the inquest which I also covered eight
years later at the high court
that Henry Paul the chauffeur that
evening was high on drink and drugs he
hadn't been expecting to work which is
why why he was drunk and he'd never
driven a Mercedes before and Muhammad
al-fahed instructed him to drive Dodie
and Diana right across Paris a routine
didn't particularly know in a very fast
car that he wasn't used to driving he
had a mini himself
and he showed off he was showing off to
the paparazzi who were outside the Ritz
hotel they could have stayed at the Ritz
hotel because they had a sweep there
they were rooted out of The Suite by
Muhammad al-fair who wanted them to stay
at his apartment and that was the
terrible thing that happened and the
other crucial thing I think versus and
the other point I was going to make
which I think is really important to
this is that Harry talks sort of vaguely
about there were flashing lights as his
mother and the car she was in crashed in
fact the paparazzi were not within one
kilometer
of the car when it crashed that came out
of the request so there were there were
none of them anywhere near that's right
or the car what is completely true is
that once they caught up with the car on
it and they realized it had crashed then
some of these ghouls did actually try
and take pictures of Diana lying in the
back of the car and that is that is
completely unforgivable but it's not
true that they were right with the car
as it went into the tunnel blinding
giant the driver potentially with with
their flash bulbs
that's absolutely right they were on
Vespers fence Vespers don't outrun
Mercedes being driven at speed they were
behind they were admittedly chasing the
Mercedes and probably trying to catch up
with it at lights or something like that
but they weren't in front of it and so
therefore they didn't cause the accident
they indeed did behave like ghouls
afterwards these were Continental
Paparazzi it has to be said they weren't
British journalists they weren't British
photographers they were Italians and
French maybe they wanted to sell
photographs to the British tabloids but
I doubt very much whether the British
tabloids which by then had learned their
lesson well I can tell you well I can
tell you for a fact that I was in The
Daily Mirror Newsroom in the early hours
of that morning about 5 a.m when we were
offered pictures of Dinah lying in the
back of the car didn't know if she was
dead or alive at that stage it turned
out she actually died I think on the way
to hospital when she got to hospital but
these pictures were offered to us and I
not only refused to even countenance
using them I rang the head of the agency
who'd sent them in advised him very
strongly to withdraw them from
everywhere he'd sent them and to leave
the country and keep his head down
because it might cost him his entire
business so this idea that we were
sitting there and salivating over
pictures of Diana in the back of the car
is completely untrue
there are many things you can claim the
tabloids for about their Royal coverage
of Diana and Charles and the breakup of
all uh that marriage but that is not one
of them uh it seems to have embittered
Harry uh very deeply you can understand
that but um as I think you were saying
earlier
um it's probably time unfortunately that
he should get over it well you know I I
would never tell anyone to get over the
death of a parent and I think but I
certainly think that him continuing to
apportion direct blame on a particular
section of the British media for the
crash that killed his mother is just
unfortunately it's not borne out by the
facts Jenny Bond you were covering
Stephen thank you very much indeed for
joining me Jenny you listening to all
that are you obviously covering all this
I mean it is to me it's a very important
point you can have a view as as Harry
and William both do that the paparazzi
are the enemy for them because they
follow them all around at all times and
obviously Diner got more attention that
I think anybody else did and the rules
did all change after she died actually
but that doesn't mean that the press the
British press were to blame for her
death that's just not true
no it's not true and I've never bought
into the conspiracy theory whatsoever
but um Harry seems to want to revive
that he was traumatized by what happened
however it happened and he has not been
able to get over it and for that that's
why I say we have to have some some
sympathy with him but uh you know he's
in the book he suggested that he would
like and William would like uh to have
the inquest reopened or the inquiry
reopened though he doesn't know what you
gained from it
um obviously that's not going to happen
but I I don't know how he will ever
um be reconciled with what happened to
his mother never be never mind be
reconciled no well you have to look
Jenny thank you very much for joining me
I mean look the bottom line and you've
got to stick to facts the inquest was
unbelievably thorough and she wasn't
wearing a seat belt and she wasn't
wearing a seat belt the car was speeding
the driver was drunk and had drugs in
his body uh and he was basically lost
control of the car on a bump in the
under bus I mean that's what happened it
is
you go go sorry
the one person who survived that Crush
was the only person who was wearing a
seat belt I interviewed him I had the
first interview with Trevor Reese Jones
a bodyguard and does he uphold Harry's
version well he all he I mean look he
wore the seatbelt and that saved his
life yeah the others weren't wearing
seat belts which isn't it does he say
that they were trying to escape the
paparazzi no no because
the paparazzi were over a kilometer
behind they were nowhere near the car so
it wasn't the paparazzi and by the way
as Stephen righty pointed out these
weren't British press these were foreign
Paparazzi just talking about this
reliving it even in a sort of fourth
hand version It's horrific it's painful
I think what we need to do is I know
this is going to be difficult for you
peers and perhaps you too Ann but it's
cut Harrison slack lift ourselves above
the parapet and think what is the royal
family for it is our first family it's a
great British brand do we want it to
look magnanimous do we want it to
represent redemption and forgiveness if
we do what about him
he's not being married
and I can tell you the best way to do
that is not to invite those yeah
anywhere near the coronation but thank
you Tessa thank you Ann appreciate you
coming in I've got to come the bread
Awards goes gender neutral to be more
inclusive and with obvious
predictability all five nominees for
best artists identify as men
do gender-neutral Awards exclude women
who are going to have a gender-neutral
panel if this these two carry on
guys give each other a hug
I don't do that